à
[Musique]
bienvenue chez guillaume j'entends comme
celle où
l'odeur de guie guie
je vais dans la chambre c'est quand même
la pièce préférée refaire l'histoire
d'une petite fille qui sinon mais si
c'est alors l aller une pièce que oui
même si
c'est sec 60
[Applaudissements]
bannissez sera furieuse un petit peu je
sais pas j'ai besoin d'être pro vie dont
je visite car je suis comme vous les
courts la semaine demain dans sa salle
de bain c'est bien celle de guillaume et
ça me semble évident et un petit message
allez je faisais beaucoup de milles donc
au réveil j'ai appelé voilà j'irai 10 kg
didier rousseau regroupe les géants si
je pouvais merci antoine de maximy
m
qu'est ce qui a vraiment cru sur un site
a
prévenu péter chez moi ok là à bâle je
pense à sa famille au mas consacrons
voisins il a dit qu'il avait une femme
gourmande sortir de
personnes chez vous non mais c'est pas
chez moi oui non non quoi comme
programme en fait chez moi non c'est non
non c'est qu'en ce bas noirs y avait
quoi vous vouliez faire quoi chez moi le
cinéma regards d'un tournoi de padel non
chez moi oui vraiment quelqu'un crée
vraiment quelqu'un vous
laissez moi ya pas de
calais digital vous avez un truc
surprise est pas au courant je parle
bien balisés ou se lancer le
gérer compte et dingo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais je m'en vais vous avez non vous
avez un truc ou pas parce que la gérer
non
je sais que
ça peut on se perdrait chez ge puis j'ai
toutes les caméras ici
j'ai déjà fait jerrycans chez vous mais
c'est pas léger pas les images n'ont
quoi tu as fait ces séries nwaas
visiblement l'époque où adam né à paris
dans le pied à terre
calme-toi pas
encore été
choisi en plus t'as pas gainey
je ne sais que j'ai digéré
[Rires]
la coupe quand il est sorti de chez moi
je suis dit tu vas tu as de la chance
ici ils pourraient bien ne pouvait rien
arriver m'a dit pourquoi tu dis c'est
l'endroit le mieux gardé de la côte
d'azur ya des caméras partout
un an m cette page avait touché toutes
les caméras ça marche voilà
l'histoire